[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute messbar
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann mit
mitreißendem sport eine schöne und das
sind die wichtigsten themen von heute
die welt blickt auf die ost ukraine was
will putin es ist diese frage die auch
die sicherheitskonferenz in münchen
beherrscht
der tag nach der sturmnacht es gab tote
und verletzte orkan böen wehten mit bis
zu 160 kilometern pro stunde über das
land und
wieder ein triumph im eiskanal leute und
mariama janka holen gold und silber im
zweierbob
die angst vor einem krieg im osten
europas wächst die bundesregierung ruft
alle deutschen in der ukraine dringend
dazu auf das land sofort zu verlassen
eine militärische auseinandersetzung sei
jederzeit möglich
die lufthansa stockt ab montag alle
flüge nach kiew und odessa
sorge bereiten aktuell vor allem die
gefechte in der ost ukraine zwischen der
ukrainischen armee und den
pro-russischen separatisten von einer
dramatischen zunahme berichten die
beobachter der osze an der frontlinie zu
den separatisten gebieten und jetzt und
lohans habe es in den vergangenen tagen
weit über 1000 verstöße gegen die
waffenruhe gegeben christiansen
berichtet die prorussischen rebellen auf
der anderen seite der frontlinie hat das
ukrainische militär jetzt noch mehr im
blick als sonst fast acht jahre dauert
hier der krieg schon ruhig war es nie
und jetzt gibt es neue opfer
durch den feindlichen beschuss starb ein
ukrainischer soldat nachdem er durch
granatsplitter schwer verletzt wurde die
kommando führung drückt den
hinterbliebenen und freunden ihr
aufrichtiges beileid aus die
separatisten werfen der ukraine vor
einen angriff auf die besetzten gebiete
zu planen was die ukrainische regierung
entschieden zurückweist auch die usa
sprechen von einer inszenierung
seit gestern wurden nach separatisten
angaben rund 17.000 zivilisten aus
lohans nach südrussland gebracht dort
laufen die vorbereitungen in
notunterkünfte
wir packen ein was nötig ist für einen
tag sie glauben es nur für einen tag
wissen wir nicht das könnte sich ändern
wir wissen nicht wann wir zurückkommen
währenddessen rufen die separatisten zum
kampf auf männer zwischen 18 und 55
jahren sollen sich bereit machen für den
krieg ich rufe alle männer der republik
auf die in der lage sind eine waffe in
die hand zu nehmen aufzustehen um ihre
familien ihre kinder ehefrauen und
mütter zu schützen
und während die stimmung an der
frontlinie zu eskalieren droht startet
russlands präsident putin seine raketen
schon
vom kreml aus beobachtet von putin
persönlich und dem belarussischen
diktator lukaschenko
ein neues militärmanöver mit
atomwaffenfähigen raketen und
hyperschall marschflugkörpern das nicht
nur in der ukraine neue kriegs ängste
schürt
deutschland frankreich etliche andere
länder raten ihren staatsbürgern zur
ausreise die nato zieht ihre mitarbeiter
aus kiew ab axel sturm wie groß ist die
nervosität in der stadt
naja die nervosität ist da sie spürbar
aber ich würde sagen sie ist noch nicht
über die maßen groß aber dass sie da ist
das kann man den menschen ja auch nicht
verdenken die wissen ja auch nicht
worauf sie sich einstellen sollen oder
einstellen müssen auf welches szenario
niemand weiß was in moskau
gedacht geplant wird es gibt ja hab so
des szenarien raketenangriffe
bombenabwürfe artilleriebeschuss das
sind ja alles unvorstellbare dinge bei
der stadt von fast drei millionen haben
was es gibt sind unheimlich viele
gerüchte spekulationen
informationen die unheimlich breit
gestreut werden vor allem gegenüber
social media vor allem muss man sagen
über telegramm und ich habe den eindruck
da werden auch ganz gezielt falsche
informationen gestreut und verbreitet
und das beeinflusst natürlich die
stimmung der menschen hier im land die
lage in der stadt ist nach wie vor ruhig
die stadtverwaltung hat heute nachmittag
kommuniziert im falle eines echten
militärischen angriffs auf kiew würde
die stadt komplett evakuiert es dürften
nur mitarbeiter der sensiblen
infrastruktur in der stadt verbleiben
und streitkräfte also nach wie vor eine
sehr sehr unvorhersehbar
dankeschön für diesen bericht aus kiew
axel sturm war dass
us-präsident beiden ist davon überzeugt
dass russland die ukraine bald angreifen
wird auch die hauptstadt kiew auf der
sicherheitskonferenz in münchen und nach
lösungen gerungen auch der ukrainische
präsident ist dabei fordert mehr
unterstützung für sein land und eine
ehrliche aussage zum nato-beitritt aus
münchen mattes hält es ist ein
aufeinandertreffen der unterschiedlichen
erwartungen während kanzler scholz heute
den zusammenhalt des westens lobt ist
sein gast der ukrainische präsident
lenski unzufrieden mit der bisherigen
hilfe des westens
olaf scholz hatte am morgen russland
gewarnt die ordnung in europa zu
verschieben das würde auf den widerstand
der westlichen verbündeten treffen es
muss klar sein dass wir die grenzen wie
sie sind und die souveränität und
integrität der staat und akzeptieren die
da sind und das ist das einzige prinzip
des sicherheit in europa gewählt
für volandri seelands gibt ist das
deutlich zu wenig statt 5000 helmen und
warmen worten bräuchte die ukraine jetzt
eine echte beitritts garantie zur nato
ihn sagt man immer die türen sind offen
aber wenn einigen uns nicht haben wollen
sagt es uns doch ehrliche offene türen
sind gut aber was wir brauchen sind
offene antworten
trotz der kritik der ukraine ist der
westen einig wie nie die russische
aggression schweißt zusammen nahezu alle
drohen russland mit schweren
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen
sie wollen eine neue ära und die
existierende internationale ordnung zu
ersetzen
sie wollen das recht des stärkeren stadt
die stärke des rechts
us vizepräsident dan harris kündigt an
weitere us truppen nach europa zu
verlegen allerdings nicht zur
verteidigung der ukraine
unsere kräfte werden nicht geschickt um
in der ukraine zu kämpfen aber wir
werden jeden meter des nato territorium
verteidigen
die nervosität unter den westlichen
verbündeten wächst die kriegsgefahr in
der ukraine wird nicht kleiner
welchen rat haben die hochrangigen
experten in münchen anne gellinek wie
kann eine weitere eskalation verhindert
werden
tja das problem hier in münchen ist das
auch die zahlreichen außenminister die
regierungschefs und chefin kein klares
bild darüber haben was sich eigentlich
an der russisch-ukrainischen grenze
abspielt und das macht auch die
teilnehmer einer so hochrangigen
sicherheitskonferenz nervös so wie alle
anderen auch niemand weiß was putin
wirklich vorhat ob es ihm reicht den
westen weiter in an spannung zu halten
oder ob er eben wirklich eine
militärische aktion in der ukraine plant
die hier versammelten europäer rätseln
aber auch über die kommunikations
strategie des amerikanischen verbündeten
der dessen geheimdienste immer neue
daten eines eines angeblichen
einmarsches in der ukraine
veröffentlicht und auch in der
bundesregierung herrschten leise zweifel
ob es eine vernünftige strategie ist
immer alle informationen gleich weiter
zu geben dem westen bleibt nicht viel
anderes als weiter an russland zu
appellieren seine truppen von der
russisch ukrainischen grenze abzuziehen
und auf die ukraine einzuwirken sich
bloß nicht provozieren zu lassen die
lage ist also diffus auch aus münchen
kein klares bild dankeschön für diese
einschätzung anne gellinek
jetzt zum stoppen das orkantief sap hat
sich ausgetobt wie erwartet mit hohen
windgeschwindigkeiten
vor allem in der nordhälfte deutschlands
hat es spuren hinterlassen mindestens
drei menschen kamen ums leben teilweise
brach die stromversorgung zusammen und
es gab viele unfälle
volker dutschek mit einem überblick die
erste sehr schwere sturmflut seit 2013
die rad hamburg in der nacht erlebt die
feuerwehr ist im schlauchboot auf dem
weg zu einem überschwemmten auto zwei
männer eingeschlossen beide sichtlich
unterkühlte
schon gesehen ich dachte ich fahre mir
14 etwas tiefere und als ich gemerkt
habe wie tief die es war schön zuspricht
55 meter hoch war dieser kran in bremen
ursprünglich dann erfassen ihnen die
bühne und der kraft in ein bürohaus
erwischt dabei auch einen
vorbeifahrenden lkw der fahrer bleibt
unverletzt
zwei unfalltoten nordrhein westfalen in
altenberge wird das auto eines 56
jährigen von einem baum getroffen in
hopsten stirbt ein 17-jähriger weil der
fahrer einem ast ausweichen will
verspätungen und zugausfälle im ganzen
land auch in rostock über tausend
streckenkilometer sind beschädigt die
bahn rät ab morgen in den norden zu
reisen kein fernverkehr nördlich der
linie dortmund hannover berlin erweitern
jetzt noch mal die kulanzregelung
fahrkarten für dieses wochenende oder
auch für den montag gelten noch eine
woche lang ganz flexibel in allen zügen
des fernverkehrs viel wellengang auf den
inseln auch auf wangerooge hat das
orkantief in der nacht mächtig
aufgedreht dass mehr als strand räuber
die abbruchkante geht bis zu den dünen
viel arbeit für die nächsten wochen zu
90 95 prozent des strandes sind weg wir
haben nur kleine bereiche wo noch ein
bisschen sand liegt aber sonst auf einer
länge von mindestens 1 kilometer fehlt
uns der ganze badestrand entwarnung
geben die meteorologen erst mal nicht in
der nacht zum montag werden wieder
stürmer aufziehen
unwetter schäden gab es nicht nur in
deutschland auch in vielen anderen
teilen europas entwurzelte der sturm
massenweise bäume auf autos und
lastwagen um deckte hausdächer ab in
polen den niederlanden in belgien und
auf den britischen inseln starben mehr
als zehn menschen meist durch
umstürzende bäume millionen haushalte
waren zeitweise ohne strom
die korona beschränkungen werden
stufenweise abgebaut doch was es mit den
schulen sollen auch da die
schutzmaßnahmen gelockert werden der
verband der kinder- und jugend- ernste
meint ja und fordert die masken pflicht
zu überprüfen und die pflicht zur
anlasslosen corona tests aufzuheben nach
ansicht des lehrerverbands dagegen sind
häufige tests an schulen weiter nötig
die zahlen gehen weiter zurück die
sieben tage incidence liegt nach angaben
des robert-koch-instituts aktuell bei
1.350 4 die gesundheitsämter meldeten
dem rk ii binnen eines tages
189.000 105 neuinfektionen 20.000 6 84
weniger als vor einer woche 210
todesfälle kamen innerhalb von 24
stunden dazu
ihr wart ein teil unseres landes ein
teil von uns das sagte bundeskanzler
scholz in einer videobotschaft heute zum
gedenken an die neuen opfer von hanau
vor genau zwei jahren tötete sie ein 43
jähriger aus rassistischen motiven
bundesweit wurde in vielen städten der
opfer gedacht wie hier in berlin oder im
thüringischen jena die zentrale
gedenkveranstaltung fand in hanau auf
dem hauptfriedhof stadt so sondern sein
team
auch die bundesinnenministerium kam zur
gedenkfeier nach hanau und zeigte große
anteilnahme neun junge menschen wurden
ermordet weil sie für einen rassisten
keine deutschen waren für ihre
angehörigen war es ein schwerer tag die
innenministerin verspricht mehr zu tun
gegen rechtsextremismus der anschlag von
hanau hat erneut auf schreckliche art
und weise gezeigt nichts bedroht das
friedliche zusammenleben unserer
gesellschaft derzeit so sehr wieder
rechtsextremismus deshalb hat dessen
bekämpfung für mich oberste priorität in
hanau erinnern zwei jahre nach dem
anschlag viele orte an die neuen
ermordeten jungen menschen ihre
angehörigen erfahren seither große
solidarität auch heute auf dem
marktplatz in hanau kamen hunderte
zusammen die namen und gesichter der
getöteten soll niemals vergessen werden
wir haben bis heute 24 monaten deswegen
auch diesen kampf geführt weil wir von
euch unterstützung und solidarität
erfahren habe sie kämpfen um antworten
denn viele fragen sind noch offen warum
war der notruf für willy bauer nicht
erreichbar er hatte den täter mit seinem
auto verfolgt und dreimal erfolglos
versucht die polizei zu erreichen oder
warum war der notausgang im zweiten
tatort versperrt was wohl für zeitmesser
chemie und hansa coach zur todesfalle
wurde
wir wollten doch gar nicht hätten die
morde verhindert werden können einen
untersuchungsausschuss in wiesbaden
versucht viele offene fragen zu klären
für die angehörigen ist das sehr wichtig
in diesem jahr gibt es vier
landtagswahlen in deutschland den anfang
macht das saarland am 27 märz für die
regierende cdu bedeutet dass fünf wochen
noch zum aufholen denn die umfragewerte
für ministerpräsident tobias hans sind
nicht gut aus die spd dagegen sieht sich
im aufwind vom wahlkampagne sa berichtet
susanne freitag
der ministerpräsident macht heute mal
dünne und wahlkampf tobias ist
spitzenkandidat der saar cdu und würde
gerne wieder gewählt wenn wir vorne sind
da mache ich eine klare aussage werde
ich auch die spd saar einladen die
erfolgreiche regierungskoalition
fortzusetzen dieses land braucht jetzt
in der schwierigen phase in der wir sind
im strukturwandel stabile verhältnisse
in den umfragen aber liegt sie vorne
anke rehlinger von der spd schließt rot
gelb oder eine ampel nicht aus eine
groko übrigens auch nicht aber dann will
sie chefin sei die entscheidende frage
für die zukunft dieses landes nämlich
arbeitsplätze zu schaffen habe ich
einiges schon auf den weg gebracht und
ich will als ministerpräsidentin dieses
landes das thema arbeitsplätze zur
chefsache machen früher hatte die linke
im saarland zweistellige werte jetzt ist
die partei so zerstritten dass der
einzug ins parlament dieses mal
gefährdet sein könnte wir wollen auch
ein korrektiv nach wie vor bleiben in
der saarländischen landespolitik ich
glaube dass es dringend notwendig und
wir wollen die politik die wir
erfolgreich die letzten jahre mit
begleitet haben auch weiter fortsetzen
die afg hat derzeit keinen
spitzenkandidaten weil sich mehrere
mitglieder gegenseitig verklagt haben es
gibt drei kandidaten in drei wahlkreisen
die probleme im land nicht so groß und
dann interessiert die leute der streit
in der partei wer mit wem nicht kann das
ist muss zweitrangig sein muss die
interessen der bürger in den vordergrund
stellen und das versuche ich auch
vorzuleben die grünen sind zurzeit nicht
im landtag nach langem streit haben sie
sich auf lisa becker als
spitzenkandidatin geeinigt sie will die
partei zurück ins parlament bringen ich
sehe da eigentlich gute chancen dass wir
in den landtag einziehen aber wir müssen
noch gas geben in den nächsten wochen
auch die fdp will wieder in den landtag
wir hatten jetzt zehn jahre kroko das
ist einfach genug es geht nicht voran in
unserem land ist so riesig und so still
scheint und wir brauchen jetzt einfach
etwas neues ampel rot gelb oder wieder
groko es wird vor allem ein rennen
zwischen den parteien die schon jetzt an
der regierung sind
vorletzter tag der winterspiele norbert
mit einem doppelerfolg der deutschen
bobfahrer ja langsam wird's unheimlich
schon das achte deutsche gold im neunten
rennen im eiskanal ein souveräner sieg
von olympia debütantin laura nolte und
ihre anschieberin vor marianna janka der
erste deutsche doppel erfolg bei den
frauen im pop überhaupt
der sprung ins glück auf das
siegerpodest ist ihnen überzeugend
gelungen laura nolte mit deborra-lee wie
im entscheidenden letzten lauf konnten
sie die führung noch ausbauen fuhren
drei mal bestzeit und nahezu fehlerfrei
zu gold im zweierbob
den deutschen doppelerfolg machten
mariana janka mit alexandra burghardt
mit ebenfalls souveränen laufzeiten
perfekt bronze für elena maier stella
mit anschieberin silvia hofman knapp
verpassten khimki und lisa buckwitz ein
medaillenrang fuhren auf den vierten
platz die bobpilotinnen sorgen für die
nächste deutsche party am gold kanal von
jin jin
und auch im viererbob der herren bahnt
sich ein deutscher doppelerfolg an
dreifach-olympiasieger francesco
friedrich und sein team fuhren nach den
ersten beiden ersten von vier läufen
ganz knapp mit drei hundertstel vor
seinem kollegen johannes lochner die
entscheidung dann morgen
letzte auftritt der deutschen fünffach
olympionikin claudia pechstein in peking
drei tage vor ihren fünfzigsten
geburtstag erreichte die
eisschnellläuferin das finale des
massenstarts und belegte dort als beste
deutsche den neunten platz ob sie jetzt
die schlittschuhe an den nagel hängt
oder in vier jahren wieder antritt das
ließ sie offen
im aktuellen sportstudio heute abend um
23 uhr empfängt dunja hayali die vier
deutschen gold rodlerinnen natalie
natalie geisenberger johannes ludwig
tobias alt und tobias wendl dazu
natürlich ausführlich die fußball
bundesliga ja und da geht es für
freiburg und hoffenheim nach ihren
auswärtssiegen weiter nach oben hier die
bisherigen ergebnisse des 23 spieltag
wolfsburg unterliegt der tsg 1 zu 2 wie
auch augsburg dem sc freiburg stuttgart
und bochum trennen sich 1 1 bielefeld
schlägt union berlin 1 0 das abendspiel
köln gegen frankfurt ausführlich zu
sehen im aktuellen sportstudio
bereits gestern gewann 1 gegen
leverkusen mit 3 zu 2 die tabelle bayern
erster sechs punkte vor verfolger
dortmund beide spielen ja es morgen
leverkusen dritter hoffenheim und
freiburg klettern jeweils einen
tabellenplatz hoch leipzig rutscht
vorerst auf rang sechs für mainz geht es
gleich zwei plätze auf rang sieben und
in der zweiten tabellenhälfte ja fast
alles unverändert bielefeld und berlin
tauschen die plätze am tabellenende
augsburg stuttgart und schlusslicht
führt
und das was vom sport dankeschön bitte
die nacht bringt regen schnee glätte und
wind und auch morgen bleibt es
wechselhaft details hat gleich katja
horneffer im heute journal um viertel
vor elf spricht marietta slomka mit
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht morgen
übernimmt eliane apa reuters danke für
ihr interesse alles gute ihnen und ein
schönes wochenende
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend die orkane elena und xenapp
haben den weg freigeräumt für weitere
zum teil stürmische tiefs heute nacht
überquert uns dass die menschen und
schon morgen kommt das tief antonia
heran es bringt viel regen mit und in
der nacht auf montag überquert und seine
kaltfront an der kannst dann wieder
schwere sturmböen geben bäume die in den
vergangenen tagen gerade eben noch nicht
umgefallen sind könnten also in der
nacht auf montag um stürzen heute nacht
fällt häufig regen und oberhalb von etwa
400 meter ist auch dabei es gibt nur
starke bis stürmische böen und sie
sollten sich auf straßenglätte
einstellen denn in den mittelgebirgen
und am alpenrand sinken die werte auf
plus 2 bis minus 2 grad milder bleibt
die nacht im äußersten westen mit fünf
grad images temperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 6 grad in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und 12 grad am
niederrhein das wird ein sehr
verregneter sonntag und das hat
auswirkungen auf die hochwasser
situation denn einige flüsse in
schleswig-holstein niedersachsen sachsen
anhalt thüringen sachsen und bayern
führen bereits hochwasser die sonne
sehen sie morgen allenfalls mir am
vormittag an der ostseeküste oder auch
in der lausitz freund hier bleibt es am
alpenrand und die neue woche startet
sehr windig und wechselhaft zum mittwoch
beruhigt sich die lage schönes
wochenende